de Marie Brière et de Jean-Paul
Deslauriers qui va s'écrouler
sous le pic des démolisseurs.
Leur duplex de Mirabel,
riche en souvenirs, va bientôt
disparaître.
MARIE BRIÈRE, expropriée
- Moi, je suis née dans la
chambre ici. Ma maman m'a mise
au monde dans cette chambre-là.
Ça fait que il y a de
l'attachement, beaucoup!
- C'est ici que les deux
septuagénaires ont élevé leurs
filles, célébré les occasions
spéciales. Jean-Paul a lui-même
agrandi le deuxième étage de
l'immeuble. Son frère jumeau
habitait dans le logement du
bas, jusqu'à ce qu'ils reçoivent
un avis d'expropriation l'été
dernier.
JEAN-PAUL DESLAURIERS, exproprié
- On ne dort pas bien bien.
On fait rien que penser, penser,
penser... Ça fait au-dessus
de 8 mois qu'on pense à ça.
C'est dur pour le
- C'est stressant.
C'est physiquement, moralement,
mentalement, très pénible.
- La Ville de Mirabel
veut démolir leur maisonmaisonmn
et deux autres propriétés
pour réaménager l'intersection
de la rue Charles et du
boulevard du Curé-Labelle.
er, la municipalité
offre 269 000 $ pour leur
duplex et remet une avance
sur l'indemnisation définitive,
qui correspond à 70 % de cettess
de 188 000 $.
C'est parfaitement légal, selon
la loi sur l'expropriation,
mais le couple de retraités est
incapable de trouver un nouveau
chez soi avec ce montant.
- Les prix des maisons sont
rendus...
- 500 quelque mille puis
des affaires de même.
- Ça fait qu'on peut
pas se relocaliser
ANNE DESLAURIERS, fille de Marie
Brière et Jean-Paul Deslauriers
- Les offres condi
à ce qu'on ait une entente avec
la Ville, tout ça, c'est sûr
que ça passe pas. s
restent en bas de 10 jours sur
le marché, donc on a eu beaucoup
de difficulté à être pris au
sérieux.
- Devant l'impasse, la famille
fait appel à un avocat et dépose
une poursuite contre la Ville.
Me. SYLVAIN BÉLAIR, avocat
cabinet De Grandpré Chait
- Moi, je pratique depuis
presque 34 ans. Je n'ai jamais
vu une sussi extrussi extrussi e
que celle-là.
- Selon Sylvain Bélair,
l'offre de la municipalité
est beaucoup trop basse.
- On voit que ça prend
425 000, 450 000 $ et peut-être
même plus pour pouvoir acheter
dans le marché actuel une
propriété de remplacement.
- Un évaluateur qui n'est pa
impliqué dans le dossier croit
lui aussi que la valeur de
l'immeuble est sous-estimée.
FRANÇOIS GUERTIN, évaluateur
prea Experts Immobiliers
- Un immeuble semblable,
normalement, se vend autour de
400 000 $, même s'il est ancien.
Le terrain vaut déjà
pratiquement la moitié.
- Marie Brière et Jean-PaulDeslr
dans leur maison jusqu'au
1er juillet. La Ville exigeait
au départ qu'ils quittent
à la mi-avril, même si les
appels d'offres pour les travaux
n'ont pas encore été lancés.
D'ici là, ils n'espèrent
qu'une seule chose.
- Qu'on puisse avoir un bon
montant pour qu'on puisse
acheter une autre maison.
On demande rien que ça nous
autres.
- Un chez-nous
- C'est ça, un chez-nous encore.
- La Ville de Mirabel a accepté
d'entreprendre une démarche
de conciliation qui débutera
à la fin mars devant le Tribunal
adminsitratif du Québec.
Le couple d'expropriés espè
qu'on pourra trouver un terrain
d'entent